thank you very much Julie and thank you
all for being here for this magnificent
event before I get into my main message
I do need to pause for a moment and ask
you to join me in recognizing a somber
moment guys stever the fifth president
of carnegie mellon passed away about
three or four weeks ago guy was the
president from 1965 in 1972 so he was
literally the president who made
Carnegie Mellon University he was the
one that got up at commencement in 1967
and said we're creating a new university
by emerging carnegie institute of
technology with melon institute to
create carnegie mellon university i have
to tell you that didn't go down that
easily with that graduating class and
we're reminded of that I'm reminded that
all the time when I meet Carnegie Tech
graduates but it was a momentous time
for the university many other things
happen during guys tenure though brief a
lot did happen those seven years he went
on to a very distinguished career here
in Washington he left Carnegie Mellon to
become the director of the National
Science Foundation and from there he
became science advisor to two US
presidents so we're very proud of the
connection he had to Carnegie Mellon I'd
ask you to join me in a moment of
silence and guys stevers memory thank
you
thank you very much okay so I'm pleased
to tell you because Julie Wilson told me
to that this is the largest gathering of
Carnegie Mellon alumni outside the city
off the campus of Carnegie Mellon
anywhere any time in the history of
Carnegie Tech or Carnegie Mellon
University congratulations and I say
that with to my bosses sitting here from
Silicon Valley which claim that honor
until tonight having a magnificent event
there about a year ago but this is
wonderful as Julie said and she's
absolutely right the DC chapter has been
one of our largest and most active for a
long long time something like 90 years
actually the chapter dates back that far
and tonight you proved your tremendous
activity in your engagement in this
university thank you very much and thank
you julie for your wonderful leadership
you've been a great president of the DC
chapter please join me in thanking Julie
the theme for tonight's panel discussion
as you know is leading innovation DC and
Beyond and we use the word innovation on
purpose and with great thought I think
it's a word that sums up and captures
what Carnegie Mellon is all about better
than just about any other and we said
when we say innovation we mean it we
don't mean just invention we mean
innovation taking a new idea and taking
it all the way to a marketplace or
wherever it's being implemented you know
that about Carnegie Mellon you know that
from your time there we're interested in
finding real solutions for real problems
and it all derives from our focus on
problem solving it's still the case no
matter when you graduated from Carnegie
Mellon problem solving is the organizing
principle it's based on teamwork and
interdisciplinary collaboration we're
doing more of that now than we ever did
and we're a university that does more
than any other University in that regard
and it's based on hard work my heart is
into work of course the student body
currently thinks that we have adopted
that as our slogan as an excuse to abuse
them they are convinced they are the
hardest-working student body in the
world in history and they might be right
but you know the old saying Carnegie
Mellon was the hard part life is easy by
comparison is not so far off I mean you
are ready to have an impact when you
walk off our campus because of those
core values that are the basis for our
curricula and which leads to innovation
and we talk about innovation we mean a
couple of things first of all using our
own innovations at Carnegie Mellon for
the good of society now this is true
around the world it's true in DC it's
true everywhere you find Carnegie Mellon
at work but for a moment let me focus on
Pittsburgh you all live here now but you
lived in Pittsburgh at some time in your
lives and you've got some part of your
heart that's still connected to
Pittsburgh I hope it's a great city it's
always been a great city today it's
going through a golden period and it is
because of Carnegie Mellon University of
Pittsburgh and university of pittsburgh
medical center we are the engines for
the rejuvenation the regrowth the
reimagine ation and what pittsburgh is
all about it's a wonderful story as you
know the steel mills lent went away the
steel industry collapsed in pittsburgh
in 1981 and 82 the city of pittsburgh
are the region lost 120,000 steel jobs
just steal jobs in an 18-month period in
the early eighties that's unbelievable
when you think about a city that size
today Pittsburgh is the model and we've
sort of been unofficially adopted by the
Obama administration as the model for
how an older industrial city can remake
itself indeed during the worst of the
recession our unemployment rate peaked
out at around seven point four percent
much below the national average of
course and again it's because of the
diversified averse ification of the
economy and much of that built on the
innovations coming out of Carnegie
Mellon we spun off about 250 companies
in the last 20 years which employ we
don't even know how many people they
employed 10,000 people are more and
those are all based on Carnegie Mellon
technology done either by our faculty or
are our graduates we by the way there's
an organization called the association
of university technology managers which
collects information and about
university technology transfer Carnegie
Mellon is number two in the number of
spin-off companies per dollar of
sponsored research you'll never guess
who number one is its University of Utah
which is a great university with a great
medical school we don't have a medical
school we're way number one if you take
out medicine from that from that total
but we didn't stop there it's not just
our own spin-offs we created a building
we built a building at the edge of
campus about an opening about six years
ago specifically to attract technology
companies to create engineering and
research centers in Pittsburgh and it's
been phenomenally successful this is the
building it's got google apple and intel
in it except google's moving out because
they're growing too fast they now have a
hundred people they want to go to two
hundred and beyond and they're moving
into East Liberty remember you're so
this would have been unthinkable and
maybe it is to you right now Google in
east liberty in Pittsburgh that's the
new Pittsburgh it's incredibly exciting
they'll be just down the block from a
whole foods which in the East Liberty I
just like home yeah that's right we're
coming more like Silicon Valley you
should pardon the phrase every day and
we're not going to shed a tear over
Google leaving but we'd like to see them
stay close because the Disney research
lab which is across the street yes I
said a Disney lab is going to move in
where Google is moving out and we've got
companies lining up to get in Pittsburgh
is a phenomenal place to be and of
course the topper of all of this and the
great indication of how we made it was
the g20 as you know Pittsburgh hosted
the g20 summit in September it was
phenomenal and you all you
washingtonians follow all this stuff so
you know that when obama's press
secretary announced pittsburgh is the
host the press room burst out in
laughter
just says you are doing I'm doing right
now embarrassed laughter in their case
and the great thing is that when the g20
comes to town so do about 3000
journalists from all over the world and
each of them had to file a story
answering the question why Pittsburgh
and the answer was Carnegie Mellon in
the University of Pittsburgh it's a
great story so that's innovation
Carnegie Mellon and its impact on
Pittsburgh there's another dimension of
innovation I want to talk about which I
don't think it's going to come up in the
panel which I want to make sure you keep
in mind because it's a source of great
pride for the University and it says a
great deal about where we've been
historically and where we're headed in
the future I doubt that you could find a
university that's had a bigger impact on
the education itself through its own
innovations when we say we're innovative
of course we apply that everything we do
at Carnegie Mellon not just the things
we teach and what you do when you
graduate but what we do as well you're
probably started with the Carnegie plan
which was the basis for every one of
your education whether you know it or
not this is a president Daugherty's
brainchild he was the third President he
dreamed this up in the 1930s it started
getting men in the 1940s and became the
basis for the for Carnegie Tech in the
1950s and it's been with us ever since
his bright idea back in the 30s was
engineers should know more than
engineering what a radical thought it
was then engineers should learn about
communication skills should learn about
economics should learn about issues of
the day should be able to write a
sentence
I that's still a radical thought for a
lot of engineers of course that's
commonplace now and what be what was a
completely new idea invented a Carnegie
Tech became the standard for engineering
education around the world indeed you
can't be accredited anymore in
engineering if you don't have those
features that was invented at Carnegie
Tech now I won't go through the whole
list or I won't expand on them I'll just
run off all the things that were
invented at Carnegie Mellon gsi a 1949
totally change the face of business
education completely if you like
business schools today and you owe your
thanks to GSA a temper school supa of
course spun out of GSA and created a
completely new kind of public policy
school one which brought to bear
mathematics mathematical modeling and
economics serious quantitative analysis
and as you know we still stand alone as
the best quantitatively oriented public
policy school by the way we call gsi a
temper practice that geosci a grants
temper temper that's America and super
graduates I saw a lot of you was supa on
your thing Heinz highness it's not so
hard to say and of course named after
two great people you no doubt notice
david tepper made four billion dollars
last year and Senator Hines was not too
shabby as a public leader we're very
proud to bear those names and you'll get
used to them eventually but the list is
longer than that what was the first
school in North America to give a
bachelor's degree in drama Carnegie
Mellon of course in 1918 I think I
didn't even know this some embarrass is
saying till last fall when we celebrated
75 years of industrial design at
Carnegie Mellon it started at Carnegie
Mellon we started we had the first
academic industrial design program
anywhere who knew
and it's still innovating today by the
way design our dustrial design our
graphics design program is just ranked
number one computer science is ranked
number one again there's a long list of
great go ahead don't let me stop you I
won't get into rankings got to be here
all night doing that of course robotics
Institute started 30 years ago without
question the leading most important
academic robotics entity in the world
it's a department of our school of
computer science we invented the field
of human computer a computer interaction
now a department in the school computer
science the entertainment Technology
Center the brainchild of Don Marinelli
and Randy Pausch may you rest in peace
if you haven't been back in a while
you've got to see the gates Hillman
Center the new home for computer science
and the randy pausch bridge which
connects gates to the school of drama
and is lit phenomenally at night thanks
to some wonderful Carnegie Mellon alumni
it's very moving it's just terrific
entertainment Technology Center is well
I question the premiere game computer
game program in the world we have a
department of machine learning in the
School of Computer Science the only one
in the world there will be more we
invented computational finance I can say
that now a year ago I would have been
booed off the stage if I had said that
or the first school computer science
with a department of computational
biology thanks to Ray Lane who will be
meeting later which is joined with the
department of biology class at Carnegie
Mellon and no university would even
attempt to have departments like
engineering and public policy very weird
and the Department of Social decision
sciences people don't even know what
these things mean but they capture the
innovative interested interdisciplinary
no fear approach we take to everything
and there while they're not the first or
or maybe even the best I can't help but
note that
maybe the college that has advanced the
most in the last ten years is humanities
and Social Sciences it's really been
phenomenal if they see there are five
Hsss graduation oh and in their parents
and Dean John lahaska yeah right if they
ranked undergraduate creative writing
programs I'm sure we be number one do
you know that they ranked PhD programs
in the humanities last year this time
last year in our English department and
our history department ranked in the 30s
now mind you this is a college that
really only has existed as a college for
30 or 40 years we used to teach English
in history back then basic his engineers
had had to learn now we've got PhD
programs its stand alongside of
Georgetown Brown they're tied with brown
in history I think Georgetown in English
this is phenomenal your university that
you've always thought of as engineering
computer science business etc etc
history in English moving into
leadership roles now that's an applause
line
I find it hard to talk briefly about
Carnegie Mellon you see I get wound up
yeah just one more innovation I just
have to mention so we've always been
blessed to have this tremendous strength
in the arts alongside tremendous
strength and technology and the sciences
and now humanities and other areas and
now we've done something about and
students we get students of this very
special variety who are very talented in
the arts but they're deeply interested
in something else and now we've got a
bachelor's of humanities and arts
program that's been around for 15 years
very successfully because of its success
we now have a Bachelors of Science and
Arts program so you put together say
chemistry and architecture I don't know
biology and bassoon that's a real
combination by the way and now starting
last year we have a bachelor's of
computer science in arts this is very
cool and we get tremendous students only
a Carnegie milk the University is doing
very very well well or on a roll none of
this would be possible without the
support we get from you our alumni and
our donors your support is important to
us in every way your engagement you're
coming to events like this you're coming
back to campus and by writing us a check
absolutely your financial support is
crucial to us we're in the middle of a
capital campaign you'll be here hearing
more about it in just a moment in this
campaign is about really two things one
is engagement reaching out to alumni to
an extent that we never have before and
this has gone extremely well we have
three three times more alumni chapters
around the world today than we did when
the campaign started about six years ago
we went from two international chapters
to 14 we've had events like this in
Pittsburgh Silicon Valley New York
Washington the biggest singapore
bangalore
mumbai and new delhi and there will be
more and each of them by the way has
produced the largest alumni turnout ever
in those cities it's been tremendous to
see so engagement is very much part of
this and that will live on past the
campaign but the other part is about
bunny we need to raise a billion dollars
we've raised over 600 million thanks to
you and many others but our needs are
great it allows students and from
families with financial need to attend
Carnegie Mellon it allows us to innovate
in the ways I described before in the
ways you'll be hearing about in just a
moment so we need your help we want you
to be part of the successful campaign
and thank you very much for being here
tonight I want to make sure you know
about some notable people who with us or
with us also tonight we've got several
trustees trustee Larry Jennings and his
wife Kathy would you stand up when I do
this but hold your applause it'll go to
Larry's head ed Frank we will hear from
in a minute and ray lane stand up anyhow
gentlemen if you don't mind these are
trustees Azure my bosses give them a
warm round of applause
alumni association board members please
stand as I mentioned your name Marilyn
Bracken I know you're here Kent Benjamin
I saw him before Kevin joy I've heard
you're here and there he is and I know
Beverly wheelers here and she's the
president-elect of the Alumni
Association please join me in thanking
them I believe we have some Andrew
Carnegie society executive board members
with us tonight our Perry Cohen and
Steve pricier Perry and Steve where's
Perry Steve Thank You Perry for being
here and I want to acknowledge a member
of our parents Leadership Council
nazeera begat 0 thank you for David and
my thanks again to Julie for her
leadership of the of the chapter we're
very grateful for this I understand that
Theresa Allison the president of Heinz
college alumni advisory board is here
Teresa there she's
I'm very pleased some of my colleagues
came here from Pittsburgh to be here
tonight John lahaa see the Dean of h NS
s really is here and his wife Mary knew
Mary Lou Mary Lou they're wonderful
loyal thank you pradeep khosla the Dean
of the College of Engineering is here
and panel member / deep where'd you go
pretty we have the leadership of our
advancement division and many others
with us but I will just introduce three
of them Robbie kossak the vice president
for University Advancement j price
interim associate vice president for
alumni relations in Dave Bohan associate
vice president and executive director
here sorry I took so long and but I had
a lot to tell you and now it's my great
pleasure to introduce ed Frank who is as
you heard a member of our board of
trustees of PhD alumnus of Carnegie
Mellon and chairman of our capital
campaign and i have to tell you he's
head of the division of apple that
produced the ipad we can't get it out of
his hands so you'll understand why he's
going to read his speech off of that pen
today ladies and gentlemen ed Frank
all right Jerry as usual it reminds me
actually have another Carnegie Mellon
alumni Ivan Sutherland who once was told
by a colleague of his he said never
underestimate the power of the
professorial windbag anyway coming from
Ivan Jerry I think that's probably a
compliment anyway thank you very much
and good evening it's wonderful to see
all of you here and we've been holding
these alumni events as Jerry said around
the world and throughout the United
States and attendance has been nothing
short of stunning that so many of you
continue to be involved with your
university is fantastic in its own right
but moreover it's fundamental to our
continued success in our continued
growth as head of the capital campaign
I'd like to thank all of you who have
contributed to the financial well-being
of the University the good news is that
though we're here in Washington and
though that my temptation might be to
ask for a bailout we have no need to do
so under dr. Cohen's leadership the
university though we've met had
challenges over the last year like every
institution throughout the country we
continued dr. Cohen has really make sure
that we've taken the necessary steps to
ensure our continued financial stability
so no I'm not going to ask for a bailout
but I do have another proposition that
I'd like to give to you in these
globally challenging times politically
economically environmentally I believe
there are three things that provide the
bedrock upon which our country the
United States is able to meet these
challenges and these things are our
democracy our universities in our
philanthropy each of these don't stand
alone but I think are inextricably
linked in a way that when exercise to
the greatest potential really create
what used to be known and still could be
a truly great society the United States
has the world's greatest university
system this is not to say that other
universities I'm sorry other countries
don't have great universities but when
taken as a whole there is no country
that has a university system is great as
ours this is why so many people come
from
many other countries to be educated here
and in doing so in educating these
people I think we help the world meet
the challenges that i mentioned above
but also we make the world a safer and a
better place there are two reasons I
think that we have the world's greatest
university system the first is because
we have the world's greatest democracy
and I firmly believe that the two go
hand in hand that is to say that great
academic freedom is built upon great
political freedom of that I think there
can be no doubt but further I think our
democracy was built on the idea that
challenging the status quo is not merely
a good thing to do it's a great thing to
do and I believe that what makes our
universities great is that our students
are not merely taught but indeed are
expected to challenge their professors
and as a result we educate men and women
who become creators of new business new
our new technology and ultimately new
capital and it's this capital creation
that leads to the past of my Trinity
philanthropy because the reason we have
a great university system the other
reason we have is not merely the great
democracy we live in but it's great
philanthropy men and women of means and
vision have donated their time and their
resources to ensure that our
universities continue to grow continue
to inspire and continue to innovate the
result is that our country becomes
stronger our economy more vital in our
culture richer now when people talk
about Carnegie Mellon they rightfully
talk about Andrew Carnegie he was indeed
a great industrialist a wonderful
philanthropist and a true visionary
nonetheless this afternoon Sarah and I
went over to the National Gallery and
while looking at the you know all these
institutions I don't know if you do this
but when I go in I always look at who's
donated to them and when you go into the
National Gallery whichever wing you go
into you see one name ok you soup
actually lots of names but you see one
name above all the names and it's the
name melon yes it's that melon
okay and we learned two things first of
all we learned that not a single work in
the National Gallery was bought by
public funds it was all bought it's all
private donation and the second is that
the melon family created this great
national treasure okay and I know you'll
be pleased to know and this is
absolutely true I know it sounds like I
made this up but I promise you and Sarah
in my life would be your witness we were
in the Rotunda there's this beautiful
rotunda with these beautiful columns in
the National Gallery and we were walking
by and we the Sun was looking at the
plaque by the fountain there and he said
to his mom he said yeah it's it's you
know Mom melon the melon of Carnegie
Mellon University okay and I so it's
interesting that Andrew Mellon when
creating the National Gallery asked that
his name not be on the building paul
mellon who really was responsible for
the new wing which is incredible in its
own right continued the tradition but
what the melon family really did in
creating this institution is recognized
that when an institution is as important
to you as the national gallery was to
the melon family that its continued
success and growth require continued
support that is as great as their first
contribution was there further
contributions were required and that's
why there isn't just the national
gallery there's the new wing to the
national gallery and so it's in this
vein that i'd like to ask all of you who
have already given to carnegie mellon to
give again just as the melons have
helped create one of the world's great
art museums and from an incredible
collection of art um you and they have
helped create one of the world's great
universities but our job is not finished
our democracy our university require our
continued philanthropy I hope like the
melon family you take the opportunity to
take a great institution and make it
even greater and for those of you who
have not yet contributed I ask that you
join the Carnegie's the melons and so
many of your fellow alumni and friends
in contributing to the University though
your name may not be on the door you are
still incredibly vital to the
future of Carnegie Mellon so now
speaking of someone who has taken the
opportunity to make the university
grader I'd like to introduce ray lane
ray is not a graduate of Carnegie Mellon
but his father is his father was but
nonetheless though not a graduate ray
and his wife Stephanie have met the
philanthropic challenge of giving to the
University and like the melon family
they have done so multiple times in
significant ways but equally important
ray has also given of his time first by
becoming a trustee then by becoming my
predecessor as chair of the campaign and
now his head of the board of trustees
and I can tell you that that is no minor
thing to go do the time commitment
required to that for someone who I just
understood not only as a successful
venture capitalist but now is CEO of a
of a start-up basically is it's it's
amazing that ray chose to do that and so
its chairman of the board of trustees
I'd like to introduce Ray who is going
to host tonight's panel right
thank you and it's a real honor be here
when I was head of the capital campaign
and was thinking about who I could
select as a nominee to run the campaign
from here on out I thought well maybe
pick somebody like me it just simply
stands out in front of people and says
dig deep and deep and do it often or
find somebody that tells eloquent
stories like Eddie Frank to lead up to
dig deep and do it often ok ed thank you
it's a great great great story I'm
really honored to be here too to chair
the panel wheat panel we had a great
time in Silicon Valley we had a great
time in New York and and I'm sure just
like there's a bigger turnout here than
in both those locations this is going to
be a more exciting panel than those
locations my passion for Carnegie Mellon
is ed said goes goes deep and goes way
back in fact I'm starting on my second
60 years to to deepen my passion for
Carnegie Mellon my father started me at
about two years old because he was
attending Carnegie Mellon about that
time and wood wood wood and and finished
his degree at night school in CIT and
would take me to campus a lot one of the
most compelling things about the
university to me has been CMU's role as
an engine of innovation and when you
think about Carnegie Mellon as we
thought about the campaign theme we
thought innovation that we had to use
that it was such an obvious thing when
something is so native his innovation in
Carnegie Mellon together we had to use
it as part of the campaign when I was at
booz allen i was a partner in booze alan
for 12 years and then when i was at
oracle CMU was always at the top of our
list to go get innovative graduates it
was because of the innovation especially
at Oracle where CMU was the top
recruiting venue for four years in a row
in the late 80s it was the the go-to
place to get all
developers that would develop the
products that took us well into the 90s
and and and this decade so it is it is
synonymous with the with with CMU's
reputation and and that's what we're
here to talk about tonight just as
carnegie mellon university played a
critical role as the birthplace of the
computer science industry more than
fifty years ago it's actually scary to
think that i was there at the beginning
of an industry but it's true and that
same cycle is happening with new
emerging industries today and carnegie
mellon stands at the forefront of doing
exactly what it did in so many fields
fifty years ago or further back once
again looking ahead and we'll talk about
a couple of those fields ed mentioned a
particular interest that my wife
Stephanie and I had that really brought
together a lot in our lives that work is
in computational biology stephanie and i
believe the lane center for
computational biology will make carnegie
mellon a birthplace for a new era of
diagnosis and treatment of devastating
diseases including cancer which she and
i have personally battled not ourselves
but in our families and our friends many
times it's impossible spend time with
faculty and students of the lane center
and not grasp how the work they're doing
will bring us closer to the age of
personalized medical treatment and
that's where we're headed we're headed
that you know understanding that each of
us has a different genome as a dirt
makeup we have a different treatment we
have a different resolution to whatever
ailment we get and so we should be
looked at as individuals and treated as
individuals with both therapeutics and
care and that's where we're headed with
the with the lane center most
importantly though most importantly this
center allowed us to have our passions
combined so my life like long long work
in computer science Stephanie's focus on
cancer research she's a member of the
American Cancer Society has sat on their
board allowed us to bring this together
into a philanthropic output so we were
looking for something I didn't want to
just kind of say okay let's let's do
something else in computer science or
engineering she didn't want to do
something just just in another you know
kind of ACS which is primarily care for
cancer patients as opposed to research
and so we were able to bring together
and create something from whole cloth
and I dare say there's not many
universities that it can allow that to
happen that you can bring together
passions of individuals and because
there are multi disciplines at the
University we can bring together that
and create something from whole cloth
and I guarantee if not today and and I
think today we are a leader in what we
do but years and decades from now we
will continue to be the leader in
computational biology not for its
biology not just for its computation but
for the combined skills that it that it
offers so so we're very proud to have
have been involved in this and and and
are continuing to be proud of it so just
as though you know it's just like that
happened like computer science happened
50 years ago we're seeing now new work
being done in energy in the environment
we're seeing new work being done in
global economy we're seeing new work
being done in next-generation computing
in mobility and artistic creation and
that's happening on campus today and
daresay if you went back 50 years ago 0
and solve some of the early work going
on in computer science it would feel a
lot like the work that is going on today
in any of those five or six areas where
where we will be you know hopefully many
of us will be around here 50 years from
now talking about we remember when we
remember when the work was started here
so that brings me to the panel and we've
selected panelists based upon
versity based upon their work in
different different fields to try and
stir some discussion about innovation
and bring it into the nation's capital
so we don't often associate with
innovation with the nation's capital but
it's really interesting it's really
interesting because I'll tell you is
that somebody who said I've turned my
career toward energy and environment
that I see now the marrying of policy
and economics so there's very little
today that we can do with new energy
renewable energy where we don't have to
worry about the policy that will be
developed or now even the government
funding or policy that creates funding
to make it happen and so it can't be
separated so as we think about
innovation especially in energy but I
think in other fields as well like
medicine it has to involve the nation's
capital and so I think it's an
appropriate topic for here so let me
introduce the panelists